[Music]
okay so here we got a mitsubishi mv 1200
r
wire machine
i took it apart today to do a
maintenance
give it a clean out and once over
because i've been having some issues
threading
i've been running a lot of parts and i
just haven't cleaned it in probably two
or three weeks so it was due for a
full teardown
of the upper and lower head
and that's where i'm at with it i've
already disassembled it and i've ran all
the
internals
through the ultrasonic tank
and you can sort of see them
and i've blown them off they're dry now
really clean ready to go back together
so we're going to get started
first thing i'm going to do
is reassemble the roller
lower
roller unit
when i took it apart i noticed some some
play in the shaft that was wobbly and it
was pulling in and out which is not a
good thing
so i have a rebuild kit i actually
bought three or four because this
machine
goes through them probably
once every 500 running hours i would say
it's just a maintenance item i would uh
definitely buy these bearings and
there's also this wave spring washer
i would buy that
keep it
with the machine because when it goes
bad you're going to need it
so i've already disassembled it through
the old bearings away
there's also a axle shaft seal that i
threw away got a brand new one new
bearings new wave spring washer cleaned
everything
this is your lower
retainer i guess i would call it
you have your lower roller ceramic which
i've also ran through the ultrasonic now
it's nice and clean it could be a little
cleaner but it's going to work for
what i'm doing
so this
goes on the
shaft here
and then you have your end piece that's
the channels for the water so it'll spin
that's the inner part the cover what i
like to do is put a little lubricant in
there
so you'll see it
just a little bit
i'm gonna roll in with my finger
you don't need a bunch
i'm gonna wipe my finger off here
go in there once more like this just a
thin film okay
clean it off once more
and all that's for is there's that
actual shaft seal down in there i like
it
this slide over real nice without
tearing that seal up because i've done
that before so
[Music]
put it on there
sort of spin it so it goes over there's
two bearings there's a bearing spacer
and then that that shaft seal so this is
where i'm at
sort of the bottom
you can feel it there i'm going to take
it out of you
okay just sort of seated you can see
there's that space
which there's still some more
but it has to go down
but there we go i pressed it that last
little bit
so that will get sucked up there's two
bolts that go in right here i'm gonna
start putting those in
so one bolt
feed it through oops
second bolt
i'm going to have to rotate it until you
find the holes on that lower retainer
found them
and i want to say it's this size yep
so i'm gonna screw them together
and you don't have to torque it
um
like you know until it's dead just
lightly with your fingers
that's why i'm using this little wrench
so i can't overdo it
and these wrenches actually came with
the machine so it's sort of like you
know they want you to use them
so i put it together feel a little
tension i jump to the other screw
until it's tight jump back
draw it in with the tip
okay
there we go bottoms out go back to this
one
okay that one's tight
so that's about the gap you'll see a
little over a millimeter
now i'll put some torque on it
like this
just a little bit
i want to torque it to death
jump to the other one torque it jump
back and forth
sort of like
teeter-totter to walk that shaft in
okay it's good
it's good
here we go here's my shaft i'm gonna
test it spins real nice and free let's
give it a spin test
oh yeah it maintains a nice spin there
now we check the play
there's no back and forth play check it
for wobbling there's no wobbling it's
nice and tight
before
i took this machine down earlier today
this shaft actually was pulling in and
out
and i don't it really didn't wobble a
lot but it just had that like thrust in
and out which is not good
you'll notice it in your threading like
with the wire jumps when it gets
through the upper head through the lower
head and once it hits that roller you're
going to notice your wire jump a little
the machine may stop
and pick up and that's not good so
i figured there's something going on in
the lower head and that's
one of the reasons
so now we'll install it into the lower
unit here
it goes in the side
these are left-hand threads
to counteract the way the wire gets
sucked through you want left-hand
threads that way it won't unscrew itself
you don't need to torque it to death
just nice and finger tight so you can
take it out with your fingers later
okay so that part's done
next part
this is the i would guess i would call
this the lower head itself
your diamond guides you have your lower
diamond guide that goes here
upper diamond guide there's a little
puck that gets
bolted in and then the upper diamond
guide
gets screwed into that your power feeder
feeds in through this hole
grounding straps i guess get bolted here
so there's actually a ceramic isolator
plate that gets bolted here that i took
off to run through the ultrasonic
just to clean it up you can see it's
white
you have to be careful this when you're
cleaning it if you drop it it's probably
going to shatter
and you'll have to buy a new one and
your machine will be down
while you're waiting
of course so
this is how it mounts
put it on there there's four low headed
bolts that get
screwed in
i've also i ran those through the
ultrasonic just to get them nice and
clean
so i'm gonna screw this in off camera
and i have a large ultrasonic tank it's
a fin sonic it's actually from finland
really nice unit it's out in the big
shop
and i just put all these parts in this
little wire basket and i let it sit in
there it's like three hours today i ran
it for 120 minutes
and it's you know it gets these things
really clean
you can also use a small like a dental
dental tool ultrasonic cleaner
uh they sell that with the machine it's
an option
and you're going to want to you know
clean your power feeders clean your
diamond guides
stuff like that
because a clean wire machine
is going to thread nice and it's going
to you know give you good work so
okay so those four screws right now i'm
going to put them put a little torque on
them like i said don't torque it to
depth just enough to hold it
you know this machine it's it's not like
producing vibrations while it's running
so you don't have to worry about these
like shaking themselves loose
just tight enough to hold it together
[Music]
okay there we go it's on there
you see the top that's rust from uh
machining swarf
collects in those holes and rusts over
time
that's why i like to ultrasonic that
plate
this is the lower diamond unit i guess i
would say
you sort of see it ten thousand
a little wet from the ultrasonic so i'm
going to
rub it on some alcohol there to get that
water away
blow dry it
and inspect it yep pulls clear
[Music]
looks good and you can see those there's
three holes but they're not like equally
spaced out 120 degrees
and they do that so this uh diamond
guide will
only locate one way
and you can also see there's like two
leveling screws there and when i bought
this machine those screws were never
adjusted
so i just leave them slightly backed out
so they're not influencing the
the levelness of that
diamond guide at all
[Music]
i don't know why they're there
but um
i guess they have some purpose maybe i
just still need it with the i'm only
running 10th out diameter wire maybe if
you go down the smaller wire there's a
smaller diameter diamond guide
who knows
so now i'm putting those three screws in
that hold this unit in
like that
actually i grabbed the wrong three
screws so we take them out
these are just a little too long
these go to the upper
[Music]
head those back over there
grab these
sort of set them in frame there you can
see them it's those little guys
[Music]
screw those in
definitely want to
take your time you should screw in nice
and gentle if they going hard you
probably cross threaded it or something
and you want to do that
so
those are nice and easy there we go
screw them in torque them up
put a little bit of gumption on them not
a lot
don't want to strip the heads out
okay so that's done
that's our seat in there
now there's little rubber caps that sit
in these uh screw heads
and what that does is it sort of
protects it so the
because you can see this gets grounded
out
or electrified i don't know
yeah maybe the electricity is coming
through there or ground who knows
but
this part is energized energized and
this lower head is isolated from it so
that's why you need this ceramic plate
and then you got these rubber stoppers
that you put on there so
you're not getting
anything jumping across there
from this upper head where your power
feeder is to this lower head where
your other stuff is
okay so those are in like that
and this gets mounted on here but before
i do that i need to put my rectification
plate in there it's just a little
plastic
plate you can see like this little cup
but it has all these little tiny holes
here
and i've already blew it out and cleaned
it with solvent
i'm just checking once more to make sure
all the holes are free and they're not
plugged they're free
i have noticed one time i was having
just a heck of a time threading the
machine even with the jet
and uh
i was like man so i took it all the way
apart
couldn't find anything wrong until i got
to the lower head here and this
rectification plate
one of the
holes was plugged so it was like as the
wire was getting shot as it would come
through here it must have been getting
pushed the other way and it was
stopping every time it got down there
and it just sucked so
always make sure to take that out and to
uh
keep it clean
now that i've cleaned it the o-ring is a
little sticky
there we go popped in there
line it up
screwdrivers
those also came with the machine you got
two tiny little phillips head screws
that hold this rectification plate in so
right there
like i said don't torque it a lot just
enough to hold it there it gets
sandwiched in there
once this gets put together so
there's no need to like you know
strip these out there we go
[Music]
now i'm ready to put this unit on there
you can see there's also an o-ring here
that shuts off on this surface
[Music]
take the unit
place it in there pop it in the o-ring
there we go
just sit nice and flat you can see that
i'll just take it off again
that's all there is to it
pop it in
okay now there's four screws that bolt
this ceramic
plate to the lower head
these screws get a little rusty
so i ran them through the ultrasonic
today just to
clean them up a little bit
right there
okay
hold it down
and i don't torque them down until i
have all four screws in
that way i can make sure the plate's
nice and flat before i put any torque on
it else you know because i'm worried
about cracking it so
[Music]
there we go that one's in
that one
that one's in
this one fell into the hole
grabbed it
okay
run this guy down
okay now i'll torque
a little bit
sort of you know crossing it like i'm
putting a tire
and done
now
this also has rubber washers
because you don't want the screw which
is screwed in the lower head to be able
to arc or jump across to this upper head
[Music]
so little plastic cap i also ran those
to the ultrasonic because they were a
little rusty and funky
pop those in the machine definitely if
you lose one they actually ship the
machine with like four spares just for
that
reason make sure you you always run one
in there
okay that's done
so now
i guess just to clean things up down
there
i'm gonna bolt this um like i said
grounding wires energizing wires who
knows
you hook it up behind
there's also two bolts that hold that in
i also ultrasonic those today just to
clean them
[Music]
up go up
like i said get it going
don't cross thread it
that's good here we go
this is gonna be a long video if you're
actually watching this i'm surprised
second one only finger tightened the
first one so the second one goes in easy
two
that one's in sort of wiggle it around
level it off
i'm gonna torque it down
right there
there we go that's done
now
i can put this flushing hose on this guy
there's an o-ring that i dug out
that goes in the hole there
as you can see
this guy going to swing up pop them in
there there's two long bolts
which i also ran through the ultrasonic
today
pop those in
screw him down
i don't replace that o-ring every time i
actually haven't replaced it yet it's uh
the machine's two years old
that o-ring still has some life in it
it's not like super flat yet but i will
one day they sent a spare one with the
machine
as well so
if you lose it just grab one
there you go now
i think this is a vacuum line it also
has a little
steel
rubber plated washer
threads onto the side here
flathead screwdriver also supplied with
the machine
screw that guy in i sort of keep them
pulled up because you want them out of
the way of the lower roller in case you
need to unscrew it
someday
screw him in
is acting up for some reason
there we go
right there make sure
we go that's good okay now i guess i'll
put the power feeder in
this is the power feeder it's just a
carbide plate same as the upper head
and i didn't separate them before i
ultrasoniced them so i get to play the
which one goes where game
okay this is the lower
the lower head one
i can tell just because the uh
the lines are more evenly spaced
for some reason
the upper head um
they don't space out as nice for some
reason i don't know
anyway i was on position number 15 or no
17.
so we go in here
put a little
torque on it
squish
line it up with 17.
clip it in there you go the second power
feeder you just there's this nub here
lining up with the line
on the gauge
and they're like that's millimeter
spacing so you have looks like 15 that's
right 15 positions
on the lower head then you can flip it
you got another 15.
but then you got your upper head so you
can
swap your power feeders from your upper
head to your lower head then you got
another 30 runs
so you don't really ever have to worry
about running out of a clean power
feeder
okay so now all that's together
we'll put this little biscuit guy in
here
so that's the lower diamond guide
part
which is this one
it's the same as the upper the only
difference is the lower one's always
dirtier
and that's how i know to not get them
mixed up so screw it in there
like that
without a frame here doing work
i'm gonna wipe it off i'm gonna blow it
off
[Music]
okay little puck your biscuit here
there's your diamond guy
and that one's it's like 60 thou
diameter i don't even know why it's
there it's not really doing much maybe
it sort of keeps the wire
here's your your uh
diamond guy tool comes with a machine
you got three different ones and you got
this guy pushes one out
put them on there just by hand give them
a little torque
you don't have to torque it to that so
you see there's a little dot here that's
towards the operator
we're going to set them in there
line up the dot towards the operator
three screws
put them in one
two
three
and torque them down here make sure it's
sitting flat it should
you can stone it if you want
i already did that
it doesn't get beat up that much anyway
so
one two and
three like i said finger tight and then
we'll torque them down
using the longer bit
this just a little bit there we go
okay now
diamond guide
the one that's actually ten thousands in
diameter
[Music]
and
excuse me yeah that's the upper head one
this is the lower head one you can tell
way bigger in diameter
i'm gonna blow it out real quick
these are the standard
taper angle guides i think they go up to
like 30 degrees or something
i have wide angle guides but i only run
those when i'm cutting big tapers
which isn't often so
that guy
like i said tighten them you don't have
to torque them to death just enough
right there
okay wave spring washer
which i ran through the ultrasonic today
bam
set them on there
lower flush cup that's plastic
now the fa series wires this was ceramic
and i would shatter it all the time
so that's nice
or retaining rain also ultrasonic to
today a little rusty
not a big deal
and for some reason getting this on
there is always a pain
you can really cross thread it easy
there we go
torque it down
this should float up and down on that
wave spring washer you can lock it down
but i like to run it just so it'll stick
flush under the work piece
right there
you can try to like one day i had a lot
of trouble
feeding through a really small diameter
hole
and i think it was because the the work
piece was flush with this flush cup so
as it was sucking the water out
i don't know weird stuff was happening
so i locked this cup down and it was
able to suck water from the tank in on
thread
and it actually worked a lot easier for
me i don't know if it was because i did
that or just because i thought i did
that so
i don't know
anyway that's the lower the lower head
now we're going to move on to the upper
head
so that's already taken apart i'm going
to wipe it out by hand
[Music]
blue shop towel rubbing alcohol
just going up in there
giving it a wipe down should stay fairly
clean
this is uh the flush water is always
from the clean sided filter tank
i mean even on the lower head it's from
the clean side tank but
all that swarf is getting pushed down
into it that's why those diamond guys
get dirty the upper one usually stays
pretty clean
you can see there's still a little bit
of gunk
but uh that's good make sure you didn't
tear your paper towel off you don't want
little
frags up in there
looks good
so here is the upper diamond guide
retaining plate let me blow it out
i also ran this through the ultrasonic
today
[Music]
so we got the preliminary the first
diamond guide which is the same as the
lower one it's like a 60 thou diameter
hole
uh you'll always know it's to the upper
one though because it's always like
bone white it never gets dirty
and that goes in this back hole
[Music]
and flats face out
torque it
just a little don't torque it to death
there's an o-ring that rides here
i took it out it's right there um but
first there's two little dowels this
hole
and this hole
i took them out before i ultrasoniced it
because
i've done it before with them in there
and i almost lost them
so now i know
to take them out with tweezers before i
ultrasonic
[Music]
okay that one's in
that one's it and if you lose them it's
not the end of the world as far as i
know
it just hold this is your upper flush
cup it's also plastic o-ring fell out
this
that just keeps it from twisting so if
you lose one or both of them
you should be all right until you can
buy another one
so anyway
back diamond guide dowels with the other
diamond guide
let me blow it out real quick
[Music]
that gets screwed in the top here
threads there we go
[Music]
i run it in by my fingers first
so you don't cross thread it and then
torque it
just a lot a little bit more okay
[Music]
just a little like this like
you don't want to torque it to death
because it is fragile
so
there we go
done done o-ring
in
so i'll show you now
there's also a the jet cup
ceramic
o-ring on the inside this goes over this
but
you can't install this until this is
bolted up into the head because you'll
block the vault holes
but i also ran this through the
ultrasonic just to clean it up make it
more white
and you can run this cutting tapers i
think up to 15 degrees after that you
need to you just take this out and then
you can't run jet on your threading but
it's fine this machine works really
great even without jet flush for
threading
set that out so you see the little dot
towards the operator
[Music]
and the three bolts over here
get the first one started
put the wrench in there make sure your
o-ring's up there for your flush
just put it up in there
line it up
find the bolt hole
there we go first one
[Music]
second one
third
[Music]
torque
and
like jump around and make sure they're
tight still they are okay that's good
that's good
now
jet
cup i just put it on there sort of spin
it
to seat that o-ring
[Music]
when it's dry it it really gives you a
hard time so
there spray it with some rubbing alcohol
[Music]
there we go slipped on there just make
sure it's flat because
if it isn't sitting flat your jet stream
will be pissing sideways and then you're
not gonna be able to thread
i know that from experience okay that's
flat
so
now we can do our flush cup
here's your flush cup and it's a little
dirty
that's fine though
put the o-ring in there
[Music]
drop it in the retaining ring
splash shield
over
up
push your flush cup up to align those
two dowels that i showed you
screw this retaining ring on with the
other hand make sure this spins so it
doesn't get pinched just tighten that by
hand
clean up some tools
diamond guide
last thing to go
upper power feeder now you can see
all these lines how they're all just
weirdly spaced
i don't know why it does that
but
oh well
they're cheap enough i'll just buy a new
one after i've used both sides i won't
swap up and down
i was also on number 17
up
upper head so pop it in there
use the gauge put a little on there
right about there
17. you get 80 hours of use on each
power feeder setting
i run them to 60
because well sometimes when i try to go
to 80 it doesn't work so great
okay so it's all together
take all this stuff out
and i hit the e-stop
so
undo it but first i'm going to turn the
machine off
[Music]
because i haven't turned it off in about
a week and i like to just reset its
brains
so there we go
i'll turn the machine off
and
i'll let it power all the way down
i'm going to go over here and i'll flip
the breaker off
for like 10 or 20 seconds
just to
make sure it's you know
reset
i like to do that on pretty much any
machine
done
okay power up
[Music]
power up
there we go
and then i'll run through the uh
initial start zeroing out the machine
with you
because that's always a good thing to
know
this machine
zero corner is the back left corner
and the upper head goes all the way up
to the upper limit and it'll bounce it
in zero it out
you're gonna wanna do that every time
you start the machine as well as every
time you
hit the e stop because uh it may lose
its brains
it just
it loses where it is in the world
forgets itself so
okay that's coming up
it takes a while let me empty the
chip bucket
[Music]
take the trash out too
upper head
i also like to clean off these little uh
this is your wire cutter
rub that with alcohol both of the
electrodes
as well as the pads to clean them
i don't know i feel like sometimes if
they get dirty
it doesn't cut the wires good
you'll see it go back and forth a couple
times
trying to pinch it and cut it
so yeah oh and we also need to do a wire
alignment
uh you want to do a wire alignment at
least once every week especially after
cleaning
because there's no guidance
i mean that diamond guide is just
threaded in there right so as you screw
it down it can still wander a little bit
but also this plate could be off this
upper head could be off so you want to
do a wire alignment to make sure your
wire is running straight
but
you would also want to like say you took
the machine down and you were halfway
through your work piece
and you just said screw it i have to
clean it it's not working right you're
going to want to pick up on your work
piece again because even though you did
a wire alignment
where this
you know the the cups are could be a
little different from your pickup before
so um
it's always a good idea to run a wire
alignment and pick up on your work piece
again if you still left it bolted to the
tank
so
all right it came up we're gonna hit
ready
here's your water
hit the fill button
i always keep my machine running even
when i'm uh like not cutting anything i
let it idle just so the water flows
keeps the water clean and just running
so i'm manually moving it back to this
back corner
[Music]
right about there i just do that to save
time because it'll
take forever to do it on its own
you want to come off the upper limit a
little
okay go to your screen
it's gonna be initial setting machine
base set zero point return check all the
boxes
hit start
there you'll go you'll see it run
through
the z first then it does x y and then uv
i think
something i've learned though is you
always want to make sure your z limit is
turned off when you're doing this
your machine zero point return or else
it won't work
and that's something the setup guy told
me and i forgot it but then i had to
figure it out on my own so
z limit just sets your
your upper head like if your work piece
is at two and a half inches above work
surface table
um if you set it z limit two and a half
it won't let you go farther on the head
and you'll you know keep you from
crashing which is always a good thing
so there we go we're zeroed out
i'm gonna bring the head down
just to run the first thread
probably around two and a half inches
three inches there's 2.75
so i've been running
um threading fine hole so that means
there's no flush but i'm gonna turn fine
hole off so it'll flush on this thread
i'll show you
there's the jet
nice in the center in the hole
the wire's going through
look at that it's not jumping at all
that's what you want
okay threaded now i'm gonna do a cut
just to show you
it's a cut
see those guys come in
i'm just gonna sort of tension the wire
and uh pull the tip apart
i don't know if you can
see that
but it puts a nice little torpedo
on the end of that wire so it's like a
needle going through
sometimes if it's like grounding out in
the low in the head right here
when this breaks off you'll get a ball
on the end of that tenth hour wire and
then it's going to try to thread but it
won't go through
because it just balled up a little glob
of brass on your end on the end of the
wire so
we'll thread it one more time and i'll
watch this wire
you shouldn't see any jumps
look at that just a little bit of width
that's fine
awesome so i'm going to leave it
threaded
i'm going to do a wire alignment and
then i'll be
back to machining
i'll just show you guys real quick wire
alignment you're going to want to be
two and a half inches
above the table with your upper head
i just set that with a one two three
block
it doesn't have to be super precise but
it's by the book and then
your current epack
for a wire alignment you're going to
want to be
wire speed of 12
wire tension of 13
and post tension of 14.
and that is a mitsubishi recommended
thing i even made a label and i put it
here to remind myself that's where you
plug in your wire alignment
maybe i'll uh i'll add that to this
video
so you'll see
okay let me set the wire alignment thing
up